[Musique]
tu sais ce que c'est un klaxon de
courtoisie je ne suis sûr que c'est ce
que tu as bien voulait faire non pas du
tout
avec à vous excuser lyon pourra oublier
tout ça ignorent leur tu peux y aller ce
to play
vous allez bien je suis quasiment sûr
que ce pick-up me suis un enragé de la
route compétents rap le mec
je crois pas que vous sachiez réellement
ce que c'est une mauvaise journée
et vous allez découvrir
c'est un roger mon téléphone je dis je
la tourne qui s'était défendu avec ton
ami d'accord c'est ici que commence
cette première leçon rendez moi mon
téléphone je peux pas faire ça
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce que vous voulez je peux vous
appreniez ce qu'est réellement une
mauvaise journée et vous appreniez à
dire que vous êtes désolé vous êtes
enfin réveillé je suis bien réveillé
vous allez devoir sortir le grand jeu
parce que vous allez en avoir besoin